-Our next guest stars --
is a talented actress who stars
in "What We Do in the Shadows,"
which airs Thursdays
at 10:00 p.m. on FX.
Let's take a look.
-How is this my fault?
-Because I said to you
that you're the one
to be responsible
for feeding the sire!
-What have I done?!
[ Whimpers ]
-I was meaning to. I even
wrote it on a sticky note --
"Ask Nandor feed sire."
But I never actually got around
to giving him the message.
-[ Whimpering ]
-So, you know,
I think it's very difficult
to say who's at fault, really.
-Please welcome to the show
Natasia Demetriou.
How are you, Natasia?
-I'm good. Hello.
We're finally --
We're finally Zooming.
-This is so exciting
to have you here.
I'm such a huge fan.
And thank you very much.
You've taken Zoom
very seriously.
You look absolutely stunning.
-Yes, thank you. I didn't
make -- This is just --
I didn't make an effort.
I was just wearing this.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-That's just your "hanging
around the house" clothes?
-Yeah. I just got an e-mail
saying you wanted to chat,
so I was just like, "Okay."
[ Laughter ]
-This is a fantastic show,
for those who don't watch it,
about vampires.
And it has a giant fan base
of comedy fans.
But I'm wondering if vampire
fans also enjoy the show.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah. Big-time.
Vampires, themselves,
aren't a huge fan,
'cause we're kind of
exposing them.
-Right.
-But -- And we're quite --
It's quite a secret community.
But, yeah, vampire fans love it.
And when I --
When I had Instagram,
I'd get a lot of very delicious
DM's asking me,
you know,
if I wanted to swap blood
or send articles of clothing
that may be covered in blood.
-Is that maybe why it's
a former Instagram account,
as opposed to an active?
-No.
That was the only reason
why I kept it.
And -- So I miss that.
I miss it.
-So this is -- It must be --
You know, there was --
I feel like
we're at the end of this,
like, huge vampire boom.
It was, like, very serious
for a while.
And this is the really nice,
like, sort of
taking the piss out of vampires.
Were you -- Did you read
any of the vampire books?
Did you see any of the movies?
-I was -- I mean, I --
"Twilight" was my jam.
I was -- I would --
I inhaled those books.
And by that,
I didn't even read them.
I just, like, was with them.
And then they just
became part of me.
-Did you -- Are they good?
Do you feel like I would enjoy
the "Twilight" books?
-Do you love really good things?
-Yeah.
-Then I think you'd
absolutely love them.
'Cause they're just like --
Because I know you're sort of
a brooding teenage girl.
I think that you -- For me,
it was just like that state of,
like, just being so horny
and so wanting a boyfriend
and so wanting to -- I didn't --
And then you could just, like --
I would just read them
and then just sit.
But, like, the reality is
it was just me being a teenager.
Like, sat staring at a wall,
thinking that the whole world
revolved around me.
But that's what those books,
like, evoked. They're heaven.
-Well, it seems
to tick all my boxes,
so I will be running out
to the nearest open book store
I can find.
Is it fun for you,
playing an immortal character,
to work on things
like your character's backstory?
And have you brought
any of your personal life
into the character?
-It is so fun.
It's the most fun because
you don't have to worry about,
like, storyline or narrative
or anything, 'cause you're like,
"Eh, she's been alive
for 700 years, so sure."
But, yeah, I --
Yeah, I've been --
When I first got the part,
Jemaine was very --
And Taika were very, like,
"You should channel your
Cypriot, you know, heritage."
Like, my dad's from Cyprus.
And, yeah,
I channel that a lot
'cause basically Cypriot people
are essentially just vampires.
'Cause they are --
They just care about, like, sex
and, like, gold coins,
fire, and, like, death.
If that is -- And that's --
You know, like,
and it's such a rich --
It's like the sort of
culture that just, like --
My dad's lived in the U.K.
for most of his life.
He came over
when he was, like, 11.
But, yeah, his accent
gets stronger every year.
And his --
This Greek culture.
It's just like --
You know, he, like,
just stinks of olive oil.
Like, he has olives
coming out of his ears.
And like --
-Now, I -- You, obviously,
find a lot of humor
in your parents,
but I've heard your family --
very serious people,
other than you and your brother.
-Oh, yeah, no.
They don't like that --
Humor is not a big deal.
It's like,
"I went to the shop today,
and the milk was more expensive
than I had hoped."
And, you know, everything
is very dramatic.
'Cause they're Greek.
It's the ancient Greeks.
You know, they're just, like --
Everything is
so unbelievably serious.
Like, my -- my...
my aunty --
she has had problems
with her foot
for as long as I can remember,
and it's just like --
She's just got, like,
a bunion or something.
But it's like,
"My foot is very, very,
very gentle..."
And, you know, like --
like, hold her foot in her hand.
It's like, "Touch it
with your young skin. Please."
[ Laughter ]
-Do they -- Are they --
Are they happy that you are --
you have a thriving career
in comedy?
Does that mean anything to them?
-I mean --
I mean, they know that, like,
me and my brother
are on TV and we do stuff,
but I think for them --
The thing that would
really light them up --
You know, they're just like,
"So is it 'The X Factor'?"
And you're like,
"No, it's not 'X Factor.'
It's a -- It's a mockumentary
written by Jemaine Clement,
Taika Waititi,
Paul Simms, Stefani Robinson."
You know, like your -- your --
And they're like, "Yeah,
but what about Simon Cowell?"
And, you know, they --
I think to them
TV is like "X Factor,"
"Britain's Got Talent,"
"America's Got Talent."
You know, that -- or like --
Or like the equivalent of, like,
"The Bold and the Beautiful"
in the U.K.
would be like "Coronation
Street" or something.
And I think if I was on that,
they'd be like,
"Bloody hell! Wow!"
But, for this,
they're just like,
"It's something
about, uh, dinosaurs."
Something. An old --
She's playing some --
an old thing."
-Your -- your brother
Jamie's been on the show.
He's incredibly talented.
You are both in a wonderful show
called "Stath Lets...Flats."
Sorry. It's a tongue --
It's a tongue twister.
-Yeah.
-Do you enjoy --
I've been lucky enough over the
years to work with my brother.
Do you guys
enjoy working together?
Is it more or less stressful?
-Oh, it's -- I mean, it's --
I mean, you must know.
It's just so lovely.
'Cause, like, I think in this
industry you can sometimes --
I don't know if anyone's
heard of this before --
but people can be a little bit
fake in this industry.
And it's so lovely
to be, like, on set
with someone that you're like,
"God, I actually really love you
'cause you're my family."
That's so lovely.
And then, you know, we --
It's really great to network
with him at Christmas,
you know,
in front of my parents.
-That's probably why -- I heard
that some people resent the fact
that you maybe networked
your way into the part.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Yeah, that -- that --
I do get that.
But, yeah, so, no.
It's so heavenly.
And I just -- I just --
I really do.
I love him too much.
Like, that's the only
stressful thing,
is that sometimes
I want to cradle him
like the tiny baby boy
he is in my eyes.
But, you know, he's doing a job,
and it's really unhelpful
when I'm trying to cradle him
and he's trying to film a scene.
-So, it -- Because I --
I have read him say
over the years --
because you're
the older sibling --
that, one, you guys
made each other laugh a lot,
but, two, that he was just sort
of desperate to be around you,
which I think is true
of most younger siblings.
-Yeah, most people
are desperate
to be around me, to be honest.
-Yeah. I'm getting that.
I will say. On this first
meeting, I'm getting that.
-No. Yeah.
It was -- Everyone always says
that they think he's older,
so let's not forget that I am,
unfortunately, older.
Yeah, he -- it --
it was -- we did just --
I guess,
he is the only other person
to live the way we've lived.
I don't -- You know, like,
with the sort of
weird stuff your parents do
in your upbringing.
And so it's just, like, this
frame of reference is, like --
I can just be like,
"Do that thing
that Uncle Tony did
in, like, 1996."
And he's like, "Yeah, okay.
Yeah, I'll do that."
And then...
[ Laughs ]
-Sophie,
your character on the show,
is both very sweet and perhaps
not the brightest character.
Do you enjoy that combination
of, like, a very good soul
who maybe lacks intelligence?
-Oh, yeah. I think playing --
playing people
who are maybe stupid
or a little bit, like, you know,
people who are, like, not --
who, like, don't have
self-awareness
and who aren't ashamed of it,
who just own it.
You know, Sophie's just like,
"Look here. Look.
I want to dance now,
so I'm gonna have a dance."
And, like,
I just think that is --
That is the funnest stuff
to play
because being someone who's,
like, got all their [bleep]
together, you know,
is a know-it-all,
has all the answers,
they're boring!
So -- And you're just like,
"Oh, great, this guy."
So I think to play someone
who's just like,
"I'm really stupid,
and I don't care,"
is, like, heaven.
'Cause it just --
I can just empty my brain
and just be like,
"What would a slug do?"
And then that's how I do
that character.
-Well, it's heaven to watch,
as well.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Both shows are so fantastic,
and I'm really happy
we got a chance to meet.
-Aww. Thanks so much.
-Hopefully next time in person.
"What We Do in the Shadows"
airs Thursdays
at 10:00 p.m. on FX.